خلال اجتماع للقاده العسكريين الروس قيم
الجنرال سولف الى الوضع في خرسون ليقرر
وزير الدفاع الروسي بدا عمليه انسحاب قوته
من المدينه
والاسلحه والمعدات عبر نهر النيبرو
بحسب قائد العمليات الروسيه في اوكرانيا
برو جنوب مدينه خرسانه لتتخذ مواقع دفاعيه
هناك لمواجهه الهجمات المضاده الاوكرانيه
هذا الانسحاب المحتمل يعد انتكاس جديد
للكريملينج اذا انا خرسانيه مدينه احتل
لها الروس منذ الايام الاولى لغزوه
اوكرانيا لكن كيف تشكك في روايه موسكو
وتتدخل الحذر
لا نرى اي مؤشرا على ان روسيا تغادر خرسان
بدون قتال لا يزال جزء من القوات الروسيه
في المدينه تصريحات ليست سوى مسرحيه
التي احتلتها روسيا معارك شرسه منذ اسابيع
ان نجحت القوه الاوكرانيه في التقدم نحو
المدينه وقد يمثل الانسحاب الروسي في حاله
تاكد نقطه تحول في الحرب التي تقترب الان
من نهايه شهرها التاسع